bonjour à tous c'est la fin des
questions au gouvernement on refait les
gags on refait les questions au
Gouvernement sur LCP très heureuse de
vous retrouver ici celle des pas perdue
à quelques mètres de l'hémicycle on
vient de s'achever cette séance on va
bien évidemment revenir sur le
compte-rendu avec Stéphanie Despierres
et elles a mondingava qui se trouve
salle des quatre colonnes et puis avec
nos invités ici en plateau Philippe
Vigier bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député démocrate
d'Eure-et-Loir et Aymeric Caron bonjour
vous êtes député la France insoumise de
Paris et vous êtes président de rêve
révolution écologique pour le vivant
alors on va retrouver tout de suite Elsa
mon Agava pour le débrief de cette
séance une séance mono-thématique on a
parlé que des conséquences des émeutes
urbaines de ces derniers jours et Elsa
vous revenez sur les nombreux
accrochages entre la France insoumise et
la première ministre Elisabeth borne oui
puisque c'est une véritable charge
politique qui a mené la première
ministre contre les insoumis vous sortez
du champ rép a-t-elle répété plusieurs
fois au députés insoumis sous les hués
de ceci Elizabeth borne qui à chaque
fois qu'elle répondait un député nupes
écologiste socialiste ou communiste et
bien appuyer sur le fait que eux avaient
demandé en retour au calme condamner les
violences alors qu'elles considère que
les insoumises n'ont pas fait des
critiques aussi de nombreuses critiques
que les députés de la majorité ont fait
contre les insoumis les insoumis
véritablement ciblés pendant cette
séance de questions gouvernement
effectivement et on va y revenir tout de
suite en images et avec le Son puisque
la première ministre Elisabeth borne a
répondu à une question de la députée et
les filles présidente du groupe la
France insoumise Mathilde panot écoutez
avec votre partie vous instrumentalisez
un drame vous refusez de condamner
clairement les violences vous refusez
d'appeler au calme alors que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes luttent pour
préserver l'ordre républicain alors que
des sapeurs-pompiers combattent des
incendies alors que des mères sont aux
côtés des habitants et sont la cible de
violence
des mairies et des écoles sont
incendiées des magasins pillés des élus
et leurs familles attaquées et vous vous
cherchez des coupables partout dans
toutes nos institutions républicaines
sauf chez les auteurs de violence quand
vos députés rejettent tout appels au
calme vous sortez du champ républicain
cantine de vos députés affirment que la
fin justifie les moyens vous sortez du
champ républicain
contre votre leader parle de permis de
tuer pour les policiers de peine de mort
pour les jeunes des quartiers et nous
traitent de chiens de garde vous sortez
du champ républicain
aymeric Caron vous avez entendu la
première ministre vous sortez du champ
républicain et notamment quand vous
n'applez pas au calme quand il y a ses
émeutes urbaines qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre
j'attends que je suis extrêmement
fatigué je suis même déçu ça fait un an
que je suis élu je suis rentré en
politique récemment donc
j'ai un profil sans doute un peu
particulier par rapport à cet homme de
personnes qui siègent dans cette
hémicycle et j'attends beaucoup du débat
démocratique j'attends beaucoup de ce
que les députés peuvent faire et quand
j'entends un débat qui tournait en rond
autour d'éléments de langage destiné à
simplement discréditer des adversaires
politiques franchement c'est
effectivement la déception qui qui
m'envahissait vraiment pas à la hauteur
du moment mais ce qu'il faut pas une
forme d'unité d'unité républicaine quand
on a des émeutes de ce genre est-ce que
est-ce qu'il fallait pas tout simplement
appeler au calme l'unité bien sûr moi je
serai ravi que nous soyons tous unis
dans cette hémicycle autour de sujets
cruciaux sur lesquels on peut avoir un
accord au-delà de nos divergences
politiques classiques lorsqu'un jeune de
17 ans
et tué par un policier dans des
circonstances sur lesquelles pèse peu de
doutes même si on a certains évidemment
va falloir sans doute clarifier certains
détails sur la manière dont ce jeune a
été tué mais nous avons des images qu'on
a rarement eu dans ce genre dans ce
genre de drame on pourrait avoir une
unité pour reconnaître qu'il y a un
problème un problème énorme avec la
police aujourd'hui pour reconnaître que
la manière dont ce jeune a été tué n'est
pas normal on peut avoir une unité pour
reconnaître que une cagnotte qui a été
lancée pour soutenir ce policier
recueille aujourd'hui un million un
million je crois que ça on a 400 000
aujourd'hui et que ça pose un problème
puisque c'est le cagnotte nous dit en
quelque sorte c'est un encouragement aux
policiers à continuer ce genre d'acte ce
genre d'action qui sont hors-la-loi
c'est hors-la-loi on pourrait avoir une
idée une unité pardon autour de ces
questions de ce constat et ensuite
s'interroger sur les manières d'y
répondre et c'est pas le cas et oui ça
me désole Philippe Vigier quand vous
entendez Aymeric on a l'impression que
vous ne voulez pas voir le problème en
face que vous ne voulez pas régler les
causes en fait du problème vous parlez
des conséquences moins des causes
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez lui dire
en m'exprimant j'ai dit quoi
premièrement que c'est un drame que ce
jeune soit mort 2 je faisais confiance à
la justice et pour moi la justice ça
fait partie du fonctionnement de la
République et d'ailleurs ces policiers
il est en prison ce policier
ce geste de Messi de volontaire donc on
verra on dirait au bout il y a pourtant
une présomption d'innocence elle est
toujours là mais bref pour le moment on
en est là et on verra ce qui se passera
le moment venu et je dis à Aymeric Caron
je suis un peu plus ancien que lui comme
élu mais il est observateur dans son
rôle de journaliste
j'ai vécu les attentats 2015 vous voyez
ce qui s'est passé dans ces quartiers on
peut avoir des solutions différentes
entre nous dans le respect et dans le
débat mais moi je ne peux pas accepter
une seconde j'ai été maire pendant 16
ans
acceptez une seconde qu'on casse une
bibliothèque qu'on casse un commissariat
que sache pour moi c'est totalement
intolérable parce qu'on rajoute de la
misère à la misère les mêmes vos amis
qui critiquent les services la
disparition des services publics sont
ceux qui ne disent rien ils auraient dit
on va dire stop et voyez c'est très beau
message c'est cette grand-mère cette
grand-mère donc la grand-mère de ces
jeunes qui est décédé qui a dit il faut
arrêter c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
moi j'attends c'est un débat projet
contre projet et c'est là où il y a des
difficultés pour le moment c'est le
moment de
j'allais dire pas que l'analyse d'abord
il faut que le calme revienne dans le
pays et ensuite ensuite chacun avec son
groupe politique chacun avec sa
sensibilité doit être en capacité de
faire des propositions je vois
d'ailleurs que au sein du groupe de la
nupette les communistes nous ont pas
suivi les socialistes n'ont pas suivi
madame Rousseau qui nous dit on peut
piller les magasins si on a faim non
mais attendez on est où quoi
[Musique]
finalement cette forme de violence elle
est cautionnée peut-être pas par vous
mais par certains dans votre groupe je
crois que c'est très compliqué de parler
de ce sujet
on est tous scrutés dans chacune de nos
prises de parole on est en direct et
report peut-être que parfois la formule
utilisée n'est pas parfaitement adéquate
on a des injonctions qui nous sont
faites dites ceci dites cela voilà sous
des formes de posture on ne veut pas
être dans la posture aujourd'hui il y a
une colère très très
lourde qui gronde
il faut choisir son camp mais le seul
camp que la justice s'il y a des jeunes
qui sont désespérés au point de
descendre dans la rue et de casser comme
vous l'avez dit des bâtiments qui
constituent leur environnement
la réponse simpliste c'est de dire c'est
pas bien bah oui c'est sûr c'est pas
bien on est d'accord là-dessus on
s'arrête là où on s'interroge pas sur la
raison les raisons qui font que ces
jeunes ont se réduit à cela peut-être
qu'à un moment certains de ces jeunes
sont cautionner en moins en tant
qu'observateur en tant que politique ce
qu'ils font mais peut-être qu'on est
quand même obligé de constater que ces
jeunes se disent c'est le seul moyen
pour que je sois entendu et d'ailleurs
le gouvernement porte une forte le
gouvernement porte une forte
responsabilité puisque le gouvernement a
fait passer un méchant un message très
clair il y a quelques semaines en disant
par exemple sur les retraites vous
pouvez manifester pacifiquement autant
que vous voulez il ne se passera jamais
rien
ils l'ont suivi ça les jeunes quand même
ils disent mais quand on essaie de faire
cette journée un message par les voix
les plus démocratiques possible de toute
façon on n'est pas entendu et on parle
quand même de population et ça c'est un
fait aussi c'est montrer par un certain
nombre de rapports des populations qui
vivent la discrimination sociale au
quotidien c'est un fait la-bas il y a
moins de d'infrastructures sportives il
y a moins de bibliothèque là-bas on en
voit les profs qui sont les moins formés
la-bas il y a moins de chances de s'en
sortir c'est une réalité
vous ne pouvez pas encourager la
violence avec vos propos non
vous avez mal déconné je vous ai écouté
vous avez mal écouté
on peut comprendre que s'il souffre il
peut y avoir de la violence
en tant que politique c'est de
comprendre ce qui se passe comprendre
les phénomènes je suis désolé
j'ai bien voulu vous écoutez donc je
vous en fait une chose je vous en prie
donc vos propos voudriez en élu
responsable non la violence ne mène
nulle part et ça vous ne le dites pas
parce que vous manifestement un sujet
avec cela deuxièmement la police tu suis
désolé la police nous protège et si
jamais il y a une bavure les policiers
se rend condamnés moi je fais confiance
je fais confiance aux institutions de ce
pays d'ailleurs un d'entre vous monsieur
Boyard il est même protégé parce que lui
aussi il a eu des menaces des morts moi
j'ai eu trois fois des menaces de mort
donc ça n'est pas acceptable je suis
désolé deuxièmement vous dites ces
quartiers non quand on m'ignorera ne me
dites pas que la ruralité est abandonnée
sinon on vient chez moi vous verrez tout
ce qu'on a redéployé comme service
public en 20 ans et vous verrez qu'on a
apporté plus d'écoles plus de
médiathèques plus d'accueil périscolaire
plus d'équipements je parle des
quartiers priorités
prioritaires vous vous avez bien cela
qui pardonnez-moi
dans lesquelles on est en train de
parler vous êtes en train de parler de
ceux qui qui cassent en ce moment mais
oui que ceux qui cassent mais vous vous
parlez que des cartes très prioritaires
et je vais vous dire que on a mis 100
milliards dans les quatre prioritaires
il faut pas dire les études
rien fait la rénovation c'est largement
insuffisant oui mais la réponse n'est
pas uniquement pécuniaire le problème de
la responsabilité des parents est un
sujet vous voulez pas l'aborder moi je
la mets à la fois l'aborder un gamin n'a
rien à faire avec des tirs des mortiers
dans les mains effectivement jamais tout
le monde d'autorité parentale aimerait
40 ans aujourd'hui explique que c'est un
parent idéal et que ça va du tout chacun
a ses travaux demain
des ministres dont les enfants eux-mêmes
dont les enfants eux-mêmes sont pris
dans des affaires judiciaires bon voilà
le président a dit qu'il fallait
peut-être sanctionner financièrement le
président a dit qu'il fallait peut-être
sanctionner financièrement ses parents
là à dès la première réfraction est-ce
que c'est une réponse à apporter
éventuellement pour que les les gamins
restent chez eux le soir non mais en
fait sanctionner les parents vous savez
à qui on a affaire souvent on a affaire
souvent des parents isolés des mères par
exemple qui se très tôt pour aller faire
le ménage par exemple à Paris donc ce
sont des gens qui sont souvent dans de
grandes difficultés personnelles et vous
allez rajouter du malheur sur le malheur
en sanctionnant ces personnes alors la
réponse
de vous dire je pense qu'il faut rester
massivement avec des vrais politiques
pour que les jeunes est un enseignement
de qualité qu'ils aient des
infrastructures de loisirs qu'ils aient
un avenir tout simplement toutes les
études contrairement à ce que vous dites
montrent qu'il y a aujourd'hui à peu
près 10% de la population qui est
clairement défavorisée par rapport au
reste de la population de ce pays donc
soit on en tient compte et là on est
dans notre rôle de politique on va
chercher les causes aux colères même si
on peut déplorer la manière dont on
s'exprime cette colère on va chercher
les causes et on essaye d'y apporter une
réponse alors
ça doit vous parler quand même ce plan
il a été abandonné il a pas été mis en
oeuvre comme il avait été présenté
depuis 2005 qui politique de la ville
c'est ce qu'on a pu faire je rappelle
qu'il y a eu 30 ans d'ailleurs
socialiste de gauche de droite et on a
réinvesti massivement que tu ne sois pas
réussi évidemment qu'on manque de
structures intermédiaires d'éducateurs
de rue bien sûr encore mais il y a une
chose sur lesquelles on ne peut pas et
là on aura une différence absolument
majeure dès qu'il y a violence vous
devez dénoncer vous le faites pas parce
que quelque part vous êtes bloqué sur ce
sujet d'ailleurs je vois que Mélenchon a
changé il y a quelques années il
contestait le fait que ces jeunes
puissent commettre ses actes là surtout
pas un seul mot donc franchement c'est
l'apaisement la paiement doit revenir
je suis à la tête d'un mouvement d'abord
la France insoumise est un mouvement
pacifiste je suis également à la tête
d'un grand écologiste qui revendique la
non-violence comme moyen d'action donc
vous allez vous allez vous allez pas
pouvoir mais non là encore vous mélangez
tout et sinon
des gens qui étaient présents à
sainte-solines ont manifesté de manière
parfaitement Pacifique vous confondez
sur les émeutes
reviens maintenant
on revient aujourd'hui
qui a des populations
on vous entend plus les sans tomber on
vous entend plus du tout on vous entend
plus du tout alors on va écouter c'est
pas grave écoutez-moi on va écouter à
présent Boris Valo qui pose une question
à la première ministre Elisabeth Band
qui lui a répondu on était bien au sujet
des émeutes urbaines de ces derniers
jours
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
car vous avez condamné sans ambiguïté
les violences qui ont touché de
nombreuses communes et appeler à la paix
civile à la différence de vos alliés
insoumis
et monsieur le Président vano j'entends
vos interrogations sur les racines de la
crise et les réponses que nous pouvons
apporter notamment au travers de la
politique de la ville cette réflexion de
plus long terme elle aura lieu mais je
peux vous dire que nous n'avons pas
cessé d'agir pour les quartiers et pour
la politique de la ville depuis 6 ans
depuis 2017 nous avons augmenté le
budget de l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine portée à 12 milliards
d'euros nous avons mis en œuvre les
cités éducatives nous avons dédoublé les
classes de CP et de CE1 et déployer
100000 emplois francs au bénéfice des
habitants des quartiers
toutes ces annonces aymeric Caron elles
ont servi à rien selon vous pour les
banlieues ou c'est quand même un pas
important qui a été qui a été fait
mais elles ont vraiment été
insuffisantes je le répète de manière
extrêmement calme
les études nous montrent que les
politiques mises en place ont été
largement insuffisantes et que ce
chiffre de 100 milliards est bien en
dessous de ce qu'il aurait fallu mettre
on nous le donne toujours comme un
étendard regardez tout ce qu'on a fait
mais on investit dans plein d'endroits
en France mais on a moins investi dans
les quartiers des prioritaires que dans
le reste de la France que je vous ai
tout d'abord la rénovation urbaine elle
a eu lieu il y a beaucoup de banlieue
vous allez voir l'état du logement
social c'est absolument calamiteux dans
beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits non non je
vous assure qu'il y a une vision un peu
angélique très parisienne parce que il y
a des gens qui vont pas voir très
concrètement comment les gens vivent
là-bas
discriminées et pas que socialement
d'ailleurs puisque ils sont aussi
discriminés dans leur rapport par
exemple alors officiel à la police
puisqu'on le voit bien que il y a
des jeunes qui tous les mois en France
sont tués dans des circonstances qui ne
le justifient absolument pas tué par des
forces de police quand on dit par
exemple que depuis un an et demi en
France il y a 16 personnes qui ont été
tuées lors d'un contrôle routier contre
le policier en France alors que dans le
même temps en Allemagne c'était une
seule personne ça veut dire quand même
qui a un problème de politique de
maintien de leur chez nous un problème
systémique avec la police on a quand
même aujourd'hui là encore des
situations très renseignées sur la
manière dont un certain nombre pas tous
il y a des policiers qui font très bien
leur travail je tiens à le dire dans ma
situation je travaille d'ailleurs avec
avec la police souvent de manière
totalement positive mais sauf que il ne
faut pas que l'institution les encourage
et lorsque on a une igpn qui n'est pas
indépendante qui ne punit pas lorsqu'il
faut punir et bien on encourage à la
récidive dans ce cas là dans la faute
essayant ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
quelques minutes allez-y Philippe Vigier
au fort de l'ordre en général
une fois de plus je l'ai dit aymeric
Caron
si jamais il y a des policiers comme et
des exactions si jamais ils font des
actes qui étaient inacceptables si
jamais la justice doit passer elle doit
passer et elle passera vous avez un
problème parce que a priori vous dites
déjà la police elle fonctionne pas elle
tue et systémique vous avez vous avez
parlé des 16 ou 17h je viens d'expliquer
qu'il y avait des policiers qui
faisaient très bien leur travail ça
c'était un bout de votre propos mais
tout le reste de toute façon on se
souvient très bien comment Monsieur
Mélenchon lors d'une perquisition c'est
comporter avec la session judiciaire
surtout de vous parce qu'on passe
surtout de moi je vais vous dire
pourquoi pourquoi simplement parce que
comme Monsieur Mélenchon qui n'est pas
là vous donne des heures notamment sur
les retraites en disant bloqué tout sur
tout en discuter vous
[Musique]
êtes obligés
de la semaine dernière alors vous le
voyez
l'affrontement sur lequel on va se
quitter sur sur cette affrontement ici
vous le voyez entre la majorité et la
France insoumise c'était à l'image de
l'hémicycle cet après-midi beaucoup
beaucoup de tension en tout cas sur ce
plateau et en dehors merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
séance de questions au Gouvernement sur
LCP
[Musique]